the european union's main institutions
have reached a final agreement on
sweeping reforms to the eu's common
agricultural policy or cap
paving the way for the package to enter
force in january 2015.
the agreement between the council the
european parliament and the commission
covers specific financial aspects of the
reform
for example direct subsidy payments to
certain farmers would be adjusted
and increased for small farmholders in
addition the eu will boost spending on
rural development projects in less
developed regions
the key point of the reform is to
introduce compulsory greening measures
in the cap
to help make the agricultural sector
more sustainable
farmers would also be eligible for set
up grants
the cap aims to maintain living
standards for farmers while ensuring
secure food supplies
at fair prices for consumers spending on
agriculture accounts for more than 30
percent
of the eu annual budget at the moment
while it has been progressively
decreasing in size
efforts to change the policy have proven
difficult
talks on these reforms have dragged on
for a year and a half the economic
downturn
and in particular the need to finalize
the eu's next long-term budget
have made agreement on these issues even
more complex
the deal came after eu farm ministers
reached a common position on the reforms
in talks on the 23rd of september
the package must now be formally adopted
by the council and the parliament
which should be a formality